>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Welcome, I'm Michelle Stefano,
I'm a folklife specialist at the
American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress.
We're in the Coolidge Auditorium
in the Jefferson Building
of the Library of Congress.
And just a little while ago
we were treated to a series
of dance battles organized
by Urban Artistry,
a nonprofit organization
based in Silver Spring.
And I'm fortunate to be joined
by its founding executive
director Junious Brickhouse.
And would you mind introducing
who else we have here on stage?
>> Junious Brickhouse:
Yes, absolutely.
This is Ryan "Future" Webb and
Baronhawk Poitier Williams,
and Rashaad Hasani Pearson.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
so, correct me if I'm wrong,
but what brings you all together is
Urban Artistry, this organization.
So Junious, just so people
have a better understanding,
what exactly does Urban Artistry do?
>> Junious Brickhouse: Urban
Artistry is a nonprofit dedicated
to the preservation
of urban dance culture
in its simple form
and more complex idea.
We're trying our best to be
ambassadors of our cultures,
of our communities, and do our best
to preserve what we're doing now
what's been done before we came
along so in short, yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano: And how would
you describe what urban dance is?
>> Junious Brickhouse: So that's
a question that we get a lot
and the answer is always changing,
you know, as this is living culture.
Ideally, when we first started,
saying urban dance was something
that we wanted to say to get out of
saying street dance all the time.
Especially since there was a
connotation to that, you know.
And you know, I knew a
lot of talented people
who were definitely
ambassadors of the culture
that weren't from the street at all.
So kind of thought it was polarizing
and I thought that it kind of put us
under a different light, you know,
something that wasn't really us.
So saying urban dance culture
allowed us to be authentic
to wherever we came from and the
cultures that we wanted to express.
>> Michelle Stefano: And you
founded Urban Artistry in 2005.
>> Junious Brickhouse: Yes, in
2005 that was where the work began.
It was a contemplated effort on
how we could see all the people
in our community that
weren't dancing professionally
that were dancing in the clubs
that may not have been
profession dancers or world famous.
How can we get them involved,
not just in this industry
but to hear their stories and
find out about where they're from
and the things that they were
doing and what made them tick.
And to see how broad our culture
and our communities actually were.
So it was an effort to
not just dance together
but to start the documentation
process of who are we
in all these different
communities and telling our stories.
So when we started it
was about eight of us
and Ryan wasn't with us just yet.
We knew who Ryan was but he was
away at school during that time.
But definitely Baronhawk
and Rashaad were there.
And it sounds kind of funny
now but like back then
in my head it was simple,
it was like, you know,
a lot of these people
were really talented
but they don't have all the tools.
I have some tools, I
don't have all of them.
But if I could share those
tools and I could kind of open
up what I'm doing so they
can see what I'm doing,
maybe together we can move
forward and I could do
for them what people had
done for me in the past
and basically giving me
the opportunity to be more
than just a club kid or somebody
hanging out at competitions.
You know, just broaden it out.
I saw a mistake, to me
it seemed like a mistake,
it seemed like everyone was having
fun, but people weren't very serious
about what it is that they're doing.
Dance was about fun to them,
and it was about being cool.
And I grew up dancing culturally, it
was my culture, it was my identity.
The way we dressed, the way
we talk, the movement we did,
the music we listened to.
And even if it was different
types of music, you know,
all those things I felt like
was me, was my identity.
So those tools and these ways
of thinking, I just put it out
and shared it with
these young people.
And the snag was, okay,
once you share the idea
or you provide some opportunities,
like how do you get
them to reciprocate?
So the idea was hey, okay,
if we start this project,
what you have to do
is you have to do
for others what I'm
doing for you right now.
And that's going to change but if we
stay in service to each other, like,
we can enrich our communities.
And that was the beginning.
>> Michelle Stefano: Well I'd
like to get a little
personal with each of you.
>> Junious Brickhouse: Uh-oh.
>> Michelle Stefano: So 2005
you started Urban Artistry,
but take me back to your beginning
with respect to learning about
and immersing yourself and becoming
brought into urban dance culture.
Where you're from, what
were the early days like?
>> Junious Brickhouse: So for
me the early days were simple.
I started dancing with my
family at home, you know,
like a lot of us did I think.
Dance was a way for me to
connect with my mom, you know.
And to be able to have a voice.
Like it made her smile,
it made her happy,
so I remember just
connecting to that.
And being around people
who danced, you know,
it was just kind of what we did.
I don't think that I really--
I would say like all through until I
graduated from high school like all
of the-- on a daily basis we were
dancing in our hallways or dancing
in the court of where we lived.
Like go to recreation
centers, basketball courts,
wherever people were playing
music, and talent shows
and competitions for kids.
We would frequent those
things all the time.
I don't think it was until I
moved outside of my community
that I realized that
not everybody dances.
So I think when I moved
away from Virginia
and joined the military I realized
that a lot of people couldn't dance.
And a lot of people weren't really
serious about it, like people were
like dancing was funny to them.
So people would dance around
and they'd make fun of things
and I'd be like-- that's not funny.
And like, why are you making fun?
You know, so like it felt wrong to
me because I connected with that.
When you connect with something
and it becomes a part of you
and you see someone mistreat it
or not give it the respect
due, you have a response.
So that's what dance was
like for me as a kid.
And becoming an adult and
having a certain affection
for those good old
days where, you know.
And as a soldier I could no longer
have the same childlike mind,
so to speak, and I couldn't express
myself through dance in that way,
at least not culturally,
I felt like.
I was a soldier, I
wasn't a dancer anymore.
So but even though I was still
dancing, dance even became,
in the military environment, it
became even more so important to me.
Hence starting to do this kind
of work towards preservation
and documentation about dance.
>> Michelle Stefano: And
we'll get to that in a moment.
>> Junious Brickhouse: Okay.
>> Michelle Stefano: So you
grew up in Virginia Beach
in Norfolk, Virginia area.
Set the scene a little bit
more, paint the picture.
What was the music that
your mom was playing?
What were maybe the first dances
or styles that you learned?
>> Junious Brickhouse: Yeah.
Yeah so the music, definitely,
music of-- I was born in 74 so like,
you know, the music my mom
was listening to like--
it changed throughout like the week.
You know like the weekdays
was cleaning music,
so that was like the R and B
stuff like that was mostly stuff
like Minnie Riperton, Blue Magic,
Aretha Franklin, Gladys Knight.
And the weekends would
bring, as we got closer
to Friday the music got faster.
We got, it was a lot more funk,
a lot more disco, you know.
And yeah, so that was the music
that I grew up on as a child.
I think that maybe by the time I was
eight or nine years old I started
to find my own identity with music.
And the rap thing started
to get really popular
and we didn't like a lot of that.
The stuff that you
could dance to we liked.
It was rap then, it's hip-hop now,
but at first a lot of us kids didn't
like it because it
wasn't really dance music,
or at least dance that
we identified with.
So the music that some
of the first dances
that I did was the funky
robot, the breakdown,
all that stuff from Rufus Thomas.
And my mom liked Stax,
so, like that was a lot
of stuff that she played as well.
And they actually had names of
dances like the funky chicken
and you know, all that stuff.
So by the time 77 and 78 rolled
around, you know, I was old enough
to comprehend that stuff
that had years before.
And yeah so when I started
to get my own identity
in dance I started doing like talent
shows and rec center competitions,
and then just regular like
call-out battles that we used to do
in our neighborhoods or at other
projects with other dancers.
And it really wasn't a big
deal then, but it was free.
And like a lot of us
couldn't afford to be
on football teams or
basketball teams.
So we had groups of people
who danced and hung out.
>> Michelle Stefano: A while
back you were also mentioning
to me how there was this kind
of a separation between proper,
"official" in quote, dance schools.
And then the school that occurred on
the streets and in the neighborhoods
in terms of learning from
mentors, joining or being brought
in to dance crews, that's an
alternative school that was
so often the school for
poor African American kids.
>> Junious Brickhouse: Yeah, and I
think that was definitely the case
for me, it's different
for some other people.
But for me in Norfolk there
weren't a lot of places
where a little black boy like
myself could go and fit in,
even if we could afford it.
There wasn't like very
welcoming environment.
So for us the best dancers
were people that we knew,
and people that we would see on
TV, on the old UHF channels like,
I was always a Bill Robinson fan.
I always admired that he
was teaching Shirley Temple.
I was like oh, that's an older
man teaching a little person,
he's helping her with dance.
And that seemed like something that
I was like oh that was really nice.
You know, and it was just like my
mom, my mom helps me with dance.
And I would always imagine like what
would happen if I could be a start
and I'd be on TV too like this.
And I was like no,
that's not really a thing.
We really didn't think
that something
like this would be possible.
Not because we weren't
great dancers,
but because our scope wasn't there.
We didn't have people around
us that told us hey yeah,
you're going to be
famous one day dancing.
I don't think anyone ever
said that like as a kid.
I'm not saying I need to hear
it, though, but it just says
that there's a difference.
Like pre-professional programming
and dance education is set
up in different communities
in different ways.
And I don't think-- I'm glad
that my path was that way.
It taught me to respect my community
where my community is the people
that helped me as well as this idea
that dance is not recreational,
it's cultural.
And it's deeper, it's not something
you use to only advance yourself.
You can use it to elevate people
and advance other people's
quality of life.
It's something that can
be learned with patience
and through sitting down, and it
doesn't rest in a building somewhere
like you go to dance school and
you leave and then you're informed.
No, you can get the
information anywhere with someone
who wants to share it with you.
So that's-- yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano:
That's great, thank you.
How about Rashaad, what's your
story, what brought you into urban,
the rich and varied
urban dance traditions?
>> Rashaad Pearson: That's
a really good question.
I think for me my story
starts in New York City.
Born and raised there
in Queens and in Harlem.
So specifically I just
remember being a little boy
in colonial projects like
trying to imitate my sister.
She had a group called The
Ruthless Violators and every summer,
she's going to kill me
for saying this on camera,
but every summer we would have
like family day and so in the back
which was the park with the
courts and stuff, there would be
like a talent show and her and her
group would get up there and dance.
It was primarily like hip-hop
music and a lot of Rob Base,
a lot of Kwame, Queen
Latifah, things like this.
And so they were doing the
hip-hop like social steps
of the time but in choreography.
And then in between that there was
basketball games and there was food
and most of us young kids were
like playing on the monkey bars
or climbing under the
bleachers, you know.
But the music was there
and the people were there
and everything was just so vibrant.
In addition to that, I think
very similar to Junious is
that my parents played a lot
of music around the house.
And Sundays were the days
that I remember the most
because I knew it was a good day
if I woke up and I smelled pancakes
and my dad was playing The
Dells or like The Delfonics
and you just heard these,
what do they call it,
like the oldies, the classic music.
And like he wouldn't wake me up
to clean something, you know.
And every day whatever the music
was it just depended on their mood
and like I just remember
singing and dancing,
trying to do what they were doing.
I don't think I got fully aware of
what I was doing until I moved away
from the city and I moved down here
which was I think I
was 19, it was 2003.
And I started trying to
find a community of people
to attach myself to, you know.
19, I didn't really have a plan, I
didn't know where I was going next.
I was just kind of
walking aimlessly.
And I found there was,
actually where Baron and me met,
but it was called the
DC Baltimore Pop Shop.
And there were two groups that ran
it, it was Liquid Pop Collective
and it was the Boogie Nights.
Yeah, these guys like showed
us fundamentals in the styles
of like boogalooing and
popping and locking.
And I was just like in awe, like
just a fan of it, but because I was
so excited for it, I really tried
to practice as hard as I could
to get it so I could
fit in to these guys
that were teaching me these things.
But 2005 I think my life took a turn
in terms of really being fully aware
of where I was going
and what I wanted to do.
And it was when I met Junious, we
actually met not too far from here
at a night club through a
gentleman from the Boogie Nights.
And from there it was like
being a part of Urban Artistry
and being part of our
crew, like we--
man, my education just was
so rapid, like I grew so fast
because I was finally getting tools
that helped me represent what I
was learning when I was a kid.
Helped me to figure out what I
was trying to do that day and in
where I wanted to go 10,
20, 30 years from now.
And I think like that was probably
the biggest part of my growth
as an artist and as a dancer.
So that's kind of like the
short version to my story.
But yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano:
Baronhawk, how about you?
>> Baronhawk Poitier: So I was born
in 87, I'm going to date myself.
>> Michelle Stefano: Baby.
>> Baronhawk Poitier:
Baby, yeah that's cool.
And so but I'm the youngest of
seven, second youngest of eight.
And so my older siblings were
all dancers in their own way.
So I picked up a lot of
early hip-hop social dances.
I remember my sister and my
cousin taught me the Roger Rabbit
and the running man
on our back patio,
and I will never forget that day.
But that's kind of where my-- just
picking up steps, and my mom loved
to dance, my mom loved to sing,
and she never had a chance
to pursue her own artistic goals and
careers but she always allowed all
of her children to do that
and she always pushed us,
if we liked anything, if we
showed even just 10% of interest
in anything she'd go and
buy something to go push it
and ask us to do something with it.
So we have, you know, VHS
tapes of my older siblings
on stage doing dances and you
know being in performances.
Some of my sisters are artists,
visual artists, and whatever else.
So for me I was always
surrounded by that.
And my father, he loved collecting
music, that was his thing,
all types of music; world music,
country, I always made fun of him
because he was the only person
in the house that loved country
and he played it all the time.
But so I was exposed to a lot of
different things from a young age.
And it was natural, it was
never looked at as weird,
like oh you're listening
to weird music or--
everything was acceptable, you know?
It was cool.
So when I started really picking
up dances and I started breaking
in 2001 when I was a
freshman in high school.
Me and my friends just
decided to take over a couple
of hallways every two or
three days out of the week,
after school, and we just practiced.
We didn't really, sports weren't
really a big thing for our group,
video games were but we
realized that dance was something
that we really connected with
and we really enjoyed doing it
and we practiced it so much so
that now I'm here in the Library
of Congress practicing
the same dance moves.
But it was in 2005 when I graduated
that I met Junious as well.
And we actually met via a
battle, actually, I'd called him
out just as a friendly exchange.
And he smoked me but
it was intriguing
because I was practicing a
dance style that wasn't popular
in this area and that
dance style was locking.
And there wasn't really anybody
else practicing that dance style.
So when I saw somebody
else doing it,
and he was black, I
was like oh, what!
This is amazing!
It blew my mind.
And so we developed a kinship
very quickly from that moment,
and now we're working on
a professional company.
>> Michelle Stefano: Yeah,
you're the artistic
director of Urban Artistry.
>> Baronhawk Poitier: I'm one
of the artistic directors.
I'm also DJ-ing for the group,
one of the DJ's for the group.
I've picked up producing
music as well.
A lot has happened.
>> Michelle Stefano: You mentioned
two really important words:
battling, and also locking.
Would you mind describing
what they are?
>> Baronhawk Poitier: Sure.
I'll start with locking.
Locking is a dance style from
California, from the west coast.
It started in the late
60's, in the early 70's.
It's actually the second dance
style in the battle, if you go back
in the archive and
re-watch the battle.
It's a very expressive
dance, to say the least.
It's a very explosive dance,
it's one of the upright styles
where you're kind of on your feet.
You can take it down to the floor
but it's mostly an
upright dance style.
And because you're asked
to be upright it's kind
of awkward for people.
And the motions behind it, there's
a lot of arm movement associated
with it, and it's different
from popping
where popping is more illusion-based
where you're making people
believe that you're a robot.
You're making them believe that
there's something traveling
through your body and
you're making your body look
like it's actual liquid.
Locking is not.
There's nothing illusion-based
around it.
It's just a very fun party dance.
Battling is the competition
aspect of dance.
So this is you and I or my group
and your group exchanging
rounds back and forth.
If it's in an organized battle, it's
for a time limit, if it's in a club,
it's whoever gives up
first, or whoever concedes,
it's whoever's mature
enough to concede
that they have lost this battle.
But you're exchanging dance moved to
see who has a better understanding
of the dance, who has the
most vocabulary of the dance,
who has been practicing it the
most, who is able to take the dance
and show you the fundamentals
but then also be able
to flip the fundamentals and show
you hey this is what the dance could
be and this is the advanced
portion of the dance.
And that's what battling should
be, that's what battling should be.
>> Michelle Stefano: I know today
was an organized battle, right?
>> Baronhawk Poitier: Yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano:
There was set time,
even though we went over,
which was fine, right?
>> Baronhawk Poitier: Yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano:
But I'm really intrigued
about being called out in clubs.
How often does that happen
to you or any funny stories?
Did you ever kill-- excuse me--
[ Laughter ]
I mean smoke, did you
ever smoke someone--
>> Ryan Webb: He never
killed anyone!
[ Laughter ]
>> Michelle Stefano: I
meant that figuratively.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Ryan Webb: Sure,
I'll answer that one.
>> Michelle Stefano:
And then you can talk
about your story, you
getting into dance.
>> Ryan Webb: Yeah, I've been
in plenty of call-out battles.
I started as a B-boy and
a popper and at that time,
which was early 2000's,
it was sort of the era
of organized contests coming in.
But the tradition of like call-outs
and hey I want to test my skills
against you and see where I'm
at and see where you're at,
or hey I want to check your ego,
maybe you've been saying some things
or maybe like you need to put
some action behind those words
and let's see what you got.
Like that sort of like healthy
competition was still around.
So I've done plenty, I'll
give you a little scenario
of when that happened recently.
So there's was someone
that was saying hey,
I don't know if you
should be teaching kids,
maybe you're not qualified,
maybe your groups not
qualified to teach kids.
And I was like, that's
ridiculous, like, I know my people,
we can teach, we know our
stuff, we know our history,
we've learned the culture, we know
the foundation, multiple styles,
like why wouldn't we
be able to teach kids?
So I said okay well if this guy
thinks that he's more qualified
or he wants to say something
like that about my organization,
I'm going to test his skills
and see where he's at, right?
Let the actions speak
louder than the words.
So I actually have
views via internet,
so this is something new
that's happening, right.
Before it would be like you,
me, now, when you see them,
and that can happen anywhere.
In the street, in the club, at
an organized event, whatever,
but this one was kind of like
hey, I'm calling this guy out,
I wanted to prove a point and
I wanted people to know hey,
this is what's happening.
My solution to solve this
conflict is to exchange in movement
and then talk about it afterwards.
So we met at a club, we went
18 rounds each, no time limit,
no picking of the music, just
whatever the DJ was playing.
And shook hands at the
end and that was that.
>> Michelle Stefano: Who won?
>> Baronhawk Poitier: I did.
I did.
>> Michelle Stefano:
That's a good story to tell.
>> Baronhawk Poitier: Yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano: So
if I may, what brought you
into urban dance culture?
>> Baronhawk Poitier: So, okay,
my mother originally was my first
dance teacher, not urban dance,
she's a ballerina and she
does some Broadway Jazz.
So when I was little she used
to have me performing at church.
We would do a little
gymnastics, a little formations,
a little like jazz runs and
things, simple things like that.
I eventually said hey mom
this is just not cool,
I'm going to play sports
and this is just not going
to be my thing anymore.
She was upset about that, but what
she did was when I was about 14,
15 she tricked me by showing me
Michael Jackson videos, right,
and just showing me that
kind of got me back into it.
And she didn't say oh do this, it
was just like oh look at this video.
So right, that was the smart
way to get me back into it.
So you know, that sort of mainstream
pop culture and what was being done
on TV inspired me in the very
beginning to start moving
like a popper with robotics and
tick motion and gliding in the feet.
I was also into the movies
"Breakin" and "Beat Street",
I found those next and I
wanted to break as well,
and there was always boogie boys
in those videos that were poppers
and B-boys, so I was like
these are my two things, right.
I grew up in northern Virginia out
in Ashburn near Dulles airport,
so suburb, right, not
an urban setting,
hence the mainstream
media influence.
And I told my mom I was
like hey I want to go
to this competition I saw online,
there was a dance competition.
This was about 2000.
So we drove out to D.C.
and went to a B-boy contest
that was happening at
a local dance studio.
And I started taking classes from
the B-boy instructors at the studio.
And I eventually a group at
the time called Pure Energy
and Back to Basics.
And we started going to some of the
first local battles in the area.
The first one I went to was
called Breakers Delight,
that's where I met some of
the people in the group.
And then two years later
they did the same event
with a popping contest and
I entered that contest.
So in the beginning dance
for me was very much I want
to win these battles, I want to
do cool movements aesthetically
that look amazing and drop
people's jaws and impress people.
And the longer that I did it,
the more dancers that I met,
I started to realize there was
more of a culture to this thing,
specifically after I moved
to California for college,
I was dancing with
some people out there.
But before I left I
met Rashaad in 2005
and we had a practice session
together just one time,
we had a mutual friend
that was a dancer,
we practiced together
one time and then we kept
in touch a little bit
while I was in California.
Every summer I would come
home to spend my two months
over here before I
would go back and me
and Rashaad started
training together.
And Rashaad was already carrying
the mentality of Urban Artistry
which is like, again, like we
want to have fun with dance
but let's take it seriously,
let's do dance research,
let's be anthropologists about
dance, let's learn to be leaders
within the community, let's
learn history and culture.
And he's my mentor within the
group and he started breaking some
of those elements down for me,
teaching my about the purpose
of the cypher, the
purpose of the community,
how to treat each other
in that environment.
And breaking down a lot of the
details that as like an outsider
of the culture I wouldn't
really have known.
And so for me it was important
that I did meet Rashaad
and have the relationship that we
have because he kind of coached me
through that and made
things clear for me.
Also so that I could
be respectful of being
like European-American learning
an African-American tradition.
And since then my growth has
doubled, tripled, just keeps going
up because now I'm looking at it
from a more holistic approach,
it's not just about movement.
It's everything that comes involved
with the culture, let's dig deep
in all of those different
elements and not just isolate one,
let's put it all together
and see it for what it is,
and I think that has helped
me to really grow into my own
within the culture and it
helped me to become a leader
within the community as
well and Urban Artistry.
>> Michelle Stefano: You bring
up this idea of researching
and being folklorists
or anthropologists.
I'm curious, I know BarenHawk you're
from the D.C. metro area as well,
you're from New York and the
suburbs of D.C. metro area.
I'm wondering about the importance
of place and particular styles.
And if there are any
distinctive styles to New York,
I mean I know the answer's
yes and as well as here,
but just the musical
traditions of these areas,
how did that influence you and
is there that uniqueness of place
that also was an influence
in your lives?
>> Rashaad Pearson:
Anybody want to take it?
Go for it.
>> Baronhawk Poitier: I grew
up in Beltsville which is
in Prince George's County.
And the unique thing about that
part of Prince George's county is
that I lived right off of 95.
So I kind of lived in
between Baltimore and D.C.
So I was getting Baltimore
club music when I was a kid,
and at the same time I
would flip a radio station
and I would hear D.C. Go-go.
And hearing both of those
different, very very different,
types of music happening at
the same time, it kind of--
well I was already listening
to a lot of different types
of music already, but it helped
me understand my area even more
and helped me understanding
how diverse Maryland
and D.C. really are.
From Baltimore club music they would
also mix in some house music as well
so you would hear a lot of--
we didn't even realize that they
were classic Chicago house songs,
we just thought that they
were Baltimore club songs,
but like the percolator would be
mixed in and dropped in it's just
because it was such a very
popular song, it would get mixed in
and dropped in and that's
actually Chicago house music.
And there were a lot of songs
like that, you would catch a lot
of Chicago DJ's actually
working in Baltimore
and they'd be playing a
lot of Chicago house music
so you would get a taste of that.
And on the D.C. side, go-go music is
essentially if you think about it,
it's the story of hip-hop in
D.C., that's our version of it.
And so through that I got into R and
B and they were covering a lot of R
and B songs, a lot of popular R
and B songs, a lot of hip-hop songs
of the day, a lot of
rap songs of the day.
So I was exposed to a lot of
different things just listening
to our local radio stations that
were playing the unique music here.
And those two genres were only here.
That's just two, New York had
a million things going on,
Philly had their own
music, even down south,
North Carolina had
something going on,
Miami of course had their
own thing going on, so locals
and regions definitely change
music and they change culturally
and it's fascinating
listening to it.
>> Michelle Stefano: And I know
that there're many different origin
stories for some of these styles,
but I think one story is that
B-boying, and B-girling, is--
this one story, it's very
much connected to the Bronx,
if I'm not mistaken, is that any,
would Rashaad like to
speak a bit about that?
Breaking or-- ?
>> Rashaad Pearson: I could
speak a little bit about that.
I'm not a practitioner of the style
but I have paid attention
to it for enough years.
So it is one of many
urban dances that come
from like an underprivileged
neighborhood.
I think Mean [phonetic] said
it really nice like earlier
about in terms of how it evolved
from a two-step and then you start
to build it and you step out and
maybe you'll just drop to the floor
and someone would stay on the
floor a little bit longer,
and a little bit longer, and people
started to build from each other.
I think people get inspired
by what's around them,
and I think that's really important.
Sometimes you don't
see the bigger picture.
Like, a large picture
is down the block.
Going downtown is a
big deal, you know.
And I remember growing up in
Harlem, we weren't even allowed
to even go up the ave, you now.
It was like no you
can't go down there
because there's trouble or whatever.
And so making it is
going to the Rucker,
making it is being famous
in your neighborhood.
So I think a through line for
most of the dances is going to be
that when you start to move forward
and things start to become not
so isolated to the community,
this is where there's a lot
more cultural exchanges.
So when Baron is talking about how
Chicago house music is inserted
in Baltimore city, but people
in Baltimore think
it's a Baltimore thing,
they don't realize well wait a
minute we're actually learning
something about someone
else's culture.
And it's the same thing that
was happening in the Bronx.
People were infusing
the Latin Hustle,
people were doing the rock dance,
people were B-boying and B-girling.
And so there were so many different
types of music, there was salsa
and merengue and funk and jazz
and like it was just black
music, it was just that.
I don't remember growing up hearing
someone say you're doing this dance
style, or you're doing, this is
this music, this is funk or--
it was just what was played.
And like oh play that old
song, I remember how that felt.
And so there was a lot of that.
And that was our higher
intelligence,
that was how we shared
with each other.
And it's continually
happening today.
And yeah so I think boogalooing,
locking, house, hip-hop, wacking,
punking, I mean you can go through
all the different urban dances
and common story will be that.
>> Michelle Stefano: So let's
go back to Urban Artistry.
And I thank you guys so much,
you've painted such a picture
of this rich web, interconnected
web of all these styles and genres
and their evolution and exchanging.
So how does Urban Artistry
tackle that?
Because I know you're not just in
the business of teaching, right?
You mentioned earlier
there's research.
I love that you use this
term citizen folklorous
that you've coined, that
you're all researchers
in understanding the roots
and these multiple stories.
So how does that play out with
Urban Artistry, this research arm?
>> Junious Brickhouse: So I
think it starts with the idea
of having people respect
who they are first.
Doing research about other people in
their culture and their communities
and the things that they like
and enjoy is always good,
but I honestly don't think you truly
can do that without knowing self.
And the reason why I say that
is because to learn something
about someone else you'll find
things that you disagree with.
You'll be like oh no I don't really
like that, or that's strange,
or that's weird, you know?
And if you don't feel like you know
yourself enough and that you care
about yourself enough to allow
yourself to be imperfect,
it's going to be really
difficult to accept
and understand other
people's imperfections.
So I wanted to start there.
It's, you know, when you want to
teach a white kid from Ashburn
about like what's going on in the
projects and Memphis, Tennessee,
like it's important to
teach him to love himself
and to respect what he has to bring
to the table and what he's learned
in his communities and
what he grew up with.
Because that's valuable too.
It's not this idea that just
because brown people are
doing it it's more important.
I don't think that's the case.
I think it's beautiful because it's
beautiful and it has very little
to do with the people
who are doing it.
It has something to do with the
soul and the culture behind it.
So I think that's where
we try to start.
And bringing that to
an organization means
that we have these different arms
and these different directorates
where we can encourage that.
And I'll let you talk about that
since you're our director
of education.
>> Ryan Webb: Sure, so
in terms of research,
we have a project we call
the Preservatory Project
and basically what Junious was just
explaining, it's about reaching
out to often what we consider unsung
heroes within the arts communities,
urban arts communities,
not just dance.
And we want to share their stories,
not only to give others a more
holistic approach of who's out there
and what's available in terms of
information, because sometimes even
within our, I don't want to
call it underground community,
but the subculture that we know
of, there still becomes the sort
of trendy things that happen
and certain people get
more limelight than others.
So we basically wanted to
shine light in the places
where they weren't being shined
and allow those people also
to document their own
stories from their voices,
not someone else telling
their story.
So one chapter that we do is
called boogaloo traditions,
and that is specifically for
the popping and boogaloo section
that myself and Rashaad
kind of spearhead.
So we've done some really
nice interviews so far
with different people like
Damon Frost and Boogaloo Dana
and Boogaloo Vic from
Oakland, Regis from Paris,
Sensei Bop from south central LA,
and basically it's been
a really nice thing
because not only are they able to
share what they've been through
and add their perspective
into the overall story,
but it's also just a learning
experience in general.
I'm really learning a lot from doing
it because I'm gaining knowledge
at the same time, the
things that they're talking
about are actually inspiring me.
And we try to give that back by
staying connected with these people.
We bring them out for our events and
try to honor them in different ways.
And if they would like we put
that information out to kind
of promote them and
hopefully give them some work
and different things,
more attention.
So that's basically what we're
doing in the Preservatory Project.
>> Junious Brickhouse: We also have
the Urban Artistry Dance Academy
where we have workshops and
classes throughout the week
to teach these styles.
We also have a program, a
project that we're doing,
it's a genome project that we
started doing informally where a lot
of us are getting our DNA done
and doing out family histories
and connecting with someone else
in the group who might not be
from that culture and sharing
that experience with them.
Not just the actual results but
actually art that comes from there.
Just an effort to keep us
growing because I think
as Americans sometimes
we get into that groove,
you know, we're just Americans.
And that's great, I like Americans,
but I think it's important
to also have an identity,
especially for people
who don't have the privilege
as people who may come from,
people who were separated from their
racial identities and so forth.
So I think it's important
to use that as a tool.
I know for me, when I got my DNA
done it was like this big deal,
and then when I started meeting
people that were the descendants
of the people who enslaved my
ancestors, we started connecting
and started having these
conversations, it changed my art.
You know, it changed my
work in the community.
And I think projects and
programs like that helps
to enforce what we're trying to do
when we're saying identity
is important,
just as important as culture.
Yeah, so we have all these little
sections and these programs but all
of that comes through and
is built on the foundation
of our mentorship program.
And that mentorship program
works just as simple as from me
to Rashaad, from Rashaad to Ryan,
you know, we just keep doing
that over the past 12 years.
We've kept passing on what
we're doing to other people
in our community and
outside of our community.
And hopefully they'll take and
make that same promise to continue
to do that for other people.
>> Michelle Stefano:
And on top of it all,
I mean obviously Urban Artistry
is not just about dance.
>> Junious Brickhouse: No, no.
>> Michelle Stefano: And as you were
saying, this holistic understanding
of not just dance culture,
just culture.
And identity and community and
how to foster those senses.
But I do know you also, on top
of it all, Urban Artistry puts
on 20 plus events a year?
>> Junious Brickhouse: Yeah.
>> Michelle Stefano: And they
range in all sorts of art forms.
Would someone want to talk
a little bit about that?
>> Rashaad Pearson: I
can talk about it, yeah.
Just when you said 20 I was
like wow is it really that much?
>> Michelle Stefano:
That's what he said.
[ Laughter ]
>> Rashaad Pearson: So throughout
the year we're really trying
to show how three-dimensional
we are.
Like House-- I'm sorry,
Junious, really instilled in us
that it's important to show range
in our thinking, it's important
to show range in our art and value
all the things that we can be.
And so with that we try to
extend that to local community,
national community,
and then international.
So some of the events that we
are doing here will be connected
to the Preservatory Project where
we'll hold like presentations
and we'll have like a projector out
and have people see the interviews
that took place and
we'll discuss them.
Sometimes we're doing panel
discussions where we'll talk
about conflict resolution,
how do we deal
with the battle after it was done.
Are we going to stay in our egos
or are we going to try and figure
out how to come together and
work through these solutions
and not be all in our head and
sensitive about these things.
Learning from our past,
we'll do some events
that are a bit more broad and
we'll connect dance with poetry
or we'll do some theater
productions.
And we'll try to do some
performances for children,
I think we did one at the Discovery
Theater a couple weeks ago.
We also just did a performance in
Glenn Falls, New York where we tried
to talk about current events through
theater and put our personal stories
on the stage for people
to get that as well.
Once a year we have the
International Soul Society Festival,
I believe the first
one was like 2009,
you guys correct me if I'm wrong.
And that week is just like full of
art; it's dance, it's conversation,
it's eating, it's the
laughter, it's the tears.
So 20 events, actually that might
not be how many events we're
really doing.
Because we live this
thing, so we don't stop.
This happens every day.
We wake up and it's like our
time clock is just always on,
we don't get to cut that
off like everyone else.
And I think that's the work that
isn't really visible when it comes
to urban dance because
there isn't this academia,
there isn't this school
that we can go to,
we can't wake up in the morning
and clock in and be, okay I'm going
to be-- that just doesn't happen, so
we're making our way from nothing.
And the mentorship really
helps foster how we can make
that happen better for ourselves.
We look at all the mistakes that
we made and we go okay guys,
we've got to shape up, and
this is where we start to work
in the loyalty and the
respect for each other.
This is where we start to check
each other and be like dude,
you messed that up, or girl
you need to get this better.
And so these are all
our events, you know?
The conversations that are tough,
the conversations that
are really easy.
And we just really want to make
sure that we are not unsung heroes.
We want to be in the forefront, here
we are, and be as honest as we can
so people can feel this thing
and see that this take a lifetime
of work and even something that
we might not even be around for,
and hope that it can carry
on through some other
people; my kids, their kids.
You know, this is where
we're going, so.
>> Junious Brickhouse: I think one
of the things that was key for me is
that when I moved here in 2005 from
Europe, in Europe there were all
of these different crews and
all of these dance schools
and dance programs
that were well funded
and we had corporate sponsors,
like when we had shows we would go
to Puma or go to like Nike and ask
them for gear, they give us gear,
I was like this is great!
And when I came back to the
states we didn't have that.
Like some of these
things weren't accessible.
So an important lesson
to teach everyone was
like you know sometimes the money's
not going to be there to ask for,
so we have to be able to
fund our own programming.
Yes, we can write grants and
request and ask people to donate,
but for the most part if we're
waiting for that handout,
so to speak, or if we're
waiting for that blessing,
then we could be waiting forever.
We could miss the opportunity to be
who we are because we were waiting
for someone else to
come and do it for us.
So we had to invest.
And once you personally
invest, you know,
it's like okay, I love
this even more.
I paid for it, I earned it.
You know, that's a
joke but it's real.
And I think for me that
was the drive behind that.
Coming here and seeing all of these
talented people investing in things
that didn't want to invest in them.
I mean, yeah it's fine that we meet
in the club on Saturday and Sunday
and get down, why don't we
meet on Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday somewhere else and
do something to make sure
that our organization
is run better, you know?
To make sure that we create more
opportunities for each other.
And especially when it
came to dance schools,
only most of the dance organizations
were attached to dance schools.
And I didn't come from that,
so my idea was let's just build
dance crews and a dance company.
And people were like oh well what
dance school are you guys a part of?
We're like what's that mean?
Oh yeah we rent space
from this dance school.
Oh, we're residents
at this dance school.
But we are an independent
organization, independent people
with a lot of ideas and a lot
of drive and a lot of hard work.
And I think that goes back
to like that was the spark
that I saw when I came here.
It was like, man, so
many talented people.
But that was really tough, you
know like to kind of put ourselves
out there and be like hey
guys we can do better,
and a lot of people disagreed.
Some people are just
happy with what they got.
And I was doing my best not to
seem like a big-headed dude but be
like hey you know there's
other things out there,
there's other opportunities, guys,
if you go to this country
they're doing this,
they're doing that.
And some people got it.
And I think that that's what makes
me happy, like that people got it
and they signed up for the work
and 12 years later
people are still working.
>> Michelle Stefano:
How are we doing,
can we keep going or
what do you suggest?
How are you guys doing, number one?
Yeah, you're feeling
okay, not too hot?
Okay.
>> Rashaad Pearson: It's hot.
>> Junious Brickhouse:
Yeah, it's a little hot.
>> Michelle Stefano: A little hot?
How about I ask just
two more questions,
keep it as brief as you like.
Okay. So for those who
are interested in checking
out a little more of what Urban
Artistry does or even to check
out some classes at
the dance academy,
how would they go about that?
>> Junious Brickhouse: You could
just reach us at UrbanArtistry.org
and yeah, we have our class
schedules there, our events,
what we're doing, our
staff and so forth.
>> Michelle Stefano: And is
there anything they need to do
to mentally prepare ahead of time?
>> Junious Brickhouse: I would
say just be open, you know.
Be as open as you want
people to be open to you.
We're an organization that's
very serious about our art forms
but we're also very serious
about being kind to people
and creating communities,
so that counts too.
We're not going to
hip-hop cop you to death.
You know like we want people to
come and be a part of our community,
but we're also interested in
learning about them as well.
So just come with an open mind.
>> Michelle Stefano: Cool.
For each of you, and you can answer
this of course however you'd like,
what does the future hopefully
have in store for Urban Artistry
which you're all so dedicated
to but personally as well.
>> Baronhawk Poitier:
For me, more traveling.
There're so many more
countries that are on my list
that I would love to visit.
That's my thing, I would love
to see more of the world.
That's definitely a future,
that's definitely going to happen.
>> Ryan Webb: I think this
is something that's already
in the works, but the
education that we provide
at the academy is very collegiate, I
feel it's on a level that this type
of programming would fit
very well into universities,
and I'd like to see universities all
over America including urban
dance programming, you know,
something you can major in.
Because I know if I had
that option when I was
in college I would
have chose to do that.
So I think that's one
big thing for me.
>> Rashaad Pearson: I think
more recently I've been inspired
by a talk we had a couple weeks ago
and it was mentioned
that we're all farmers.
And this really registered
because the idea
that a farmer cultivates land to
feed people, you try to make sure
that your land doesn't
get poisoned and this
like metaphor really hit home
because I'm a dad, you know,
so I have two little
girls, nine and four.
And so I thought about them
immediately and then I looked back
on all the work that we've been
doing and I was like wow okay,
this is it, we're farmers.
And so I just want to
continue to extend, you know,
giving out healthy education and
building like healthy relationships
with people around the world.
So that's what I want to do.
>> Michelle Stefano:
That's wonderful.
I know you also consider
yourself a farmer.
>> Junious Brickhouse: Absolutely.
Absolutely, until the day I die.
And then some.
You know, this is who
I am and the work
that we do is what I
want to continue doing.
We have a lot of goals but
I think my main goal is
to not stop doing great
things, you know,
in the communities
that I practice in.
To just keep enjoying life.
It's work but, you
know, it's heart work,
it's stuff that makes me feel
good, it's stuff that I know
that I can pass on to others.
So my wish and my goal
is to keep being us
and keep helping people
who want the help.
>> Michelle Stefano: And if there's
anything else you'd like to add
or something I should ask
if you feel-- are we good?
We ready to take a nap?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, well thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.